[Musique]
bonjour je dis bonjour d'ide ont apposé
fondatrice de carthage a posé pour la
première fois ses pieds sur cette terre
qu on appelle la tunisie il ya plus de
3000 ans plus de 3000 ans quelques
civilisations étrangères occupante et de
dictature passé qu'ont retenu les
tunisiens comme le son est ce qu'ils se
sont dit que si des pays étrangers voyez
dans la tunisie une place géostratégique
nous pouvions profiter
est ce qu'ils se sont dit que si l'
empire romain avait fait de la tunisie
un grenier nous pouvions nourrir toute
notre population est ce qu'on s'est dit
que si des pays comme singapour on
n'avait pas de richesses naturelles
avaient réussi à se développer à
s'imposer économiquement nous pouvions
également faire de même
non non non parce que bien que
monothéistes et en grande majorité
musulmans on aime bien avoir quelques
petits culte annexes en tunisie en
premier c'est le culte du destin le
maktoub qui pour beaucoup celui aussi de
la résignation celui finalement des gens
qui quoi qui leur arrive
quoi qu'il arrive aux leurres quoi qu'il
arrive à leur pays ont décidé finalement
qu'il ne pouvait rien faire contre ça il
ya également ceux qui vouent un culte au
village potemkine savent et qui
finalement pense que nous sommes dans un
pays en voie de développement il adore
ce terme là parce qu'ils reposent
finalement 7
certitude sur des ce sont des
statistiques qui datent de la dictature
ou également parce que ils aiment bien
voir des façades d'administration
repeinte en blanc et en bleu c'est très
esthétique pourtant derrière ces façades
là il ya une autre réalité celle d'un
pays sous-développé l'arrivée d'un pays
où finalement des citoyens ont de moins
en moins accès au droit la réalité aussi
de citoyens qui n'ont pas accès à
l'éducation et à la santé
alors je vous rassure je ne suis pas
venu ici pour vous faire une petite
liste à la prévert des causes du sous
développement
je vais pas vous casser l'ambiance
surtout après la chanson d'avant n'ont
en revanche je vois justement dans ces
causes du sous développement est une
opportunité l'opportunité de tirer des
leçons de ce qui a été mal fait de ce
qui n'a pas été de ce qui n'a pas été
fait auparavant afin justement de nous
développer
parce que finalement ce pays qui vieux
de plus de 3000 ans est un jeune pays et
les jeunes par les nombreux secteurs
d'activité qui ont été peu ou pas
exploitées
d'ailleurs le aujourd'hui notre défi
n'est pas justement de savoir pour a
excusé le sous développement mais bien
au contraire de comprendre pour nous
développer
et qu'est-ce que de plus excitant
finalement d'être dans un pays qui est
maintenant libre avec un peuple
souverain pour enfin des de l'avant
alors vous devinerez à mon vocabulaire
un peu pauvre que je ne suis ni
économiste ni sociologue
mon job c'est de créer des concepts de
bars de restaurants de boîte de nuit
c'est pas notre temps derrière sociales
ses de l'entrepreneuriat sociable et
surtout en fin de soirée alors la
société civile n'est pas mon domaine
professionnel
l'aspect civil c'est mon engagement
l'engagement d'un enfant qui a grandi à
l'ombre d'une mère analphabète une mère
qui était étrangère dans un pays dont
elle ne comprenez pas la langue
une mère qui a vécu dans un monde
qu'elle ne connaissait pas pourtant
cette merlas avait une capacité de
gestion et de communication qui était
assez développés parce qu'il faut avoir
ses capacités là pour gérer une fratrie
de huit enfants dans un pays
ranger et je me suis toujours dit mais
quel dommage finalement que n'ait pas eu
accès à l'éducation
ce serait devenue une femme d'affaires
assez féroce donc j'ai grandi avec cette
questionnements et je me suis dit mais
finalement il est peut-être là le souci
le souci d'un pays qui parce qu'il
n'aide pas les enfants à pouvoir étudier
ne participa à l'évolution sociale de la
population et donc prive le pays d'une
capacité de se développer économiquement
à partir de ce moment là la question est
plutôt la réponse est devenue comme une
évidence
il fallait en tunisie placer l'enfant au
coeur du sujet de réflexion et place et
surtout l'éducation au coeur des
solutions
nous avons un pays d'ailleurs tous les
autres pays qui ressemble à la tunisie
sont pareils c'est qu'ils ont une vision
court termiste
c'est à dire que ils les ignorent
l'enfance il ne s'intéresse pas aux
conditions de vie d'éducation à
l'épanouissement des enfants mais une
fois qu'ils deviennent jeunes et adultes
s'étonne finalement que ces jeunes
adultes ne soit pas de bon citoyen
partant de cette évidence et en
découvrant la réalité des internats
alors il faut savoir qu'en tunisie nous
avons 339 interne à quelques y plus de
cent cinquante mille élèves
ces internats sont destinés aux
populations très pauvres c'est à dire
aux parents qui n'arrivent pas à
subvenir aux besoins quotidiens de leurs
enfants ou bien qu'ils habitent dans des
hameaux isolés
donc quand j'ai découvert quand j'ai
découvert ces internats j'ai décidé
finalement de sortir de ce que j'appelle
le safari sociale jusqu'en tunisie dans
les beaux quartiers et ailleurs on aime
bien finalement quand il fait froid etc
et réunir beaucoup de cartons
alimentaires ou bien de vêtements usagés
et de partir en province et d'aller
faire prendre des photos avec la
population locale et à poster ça sur
facebook c'est le safari sociale donc je
vous dis c'est finalement il n'y a
aucune durabilité dans tout ça et on
peut changer les choses parce que la
tunisie a aussi un autre avantage en
plus que de celui d'être libre c'est
aussi de ne pas avoir de guerre
actuellement n'aura pas sur la
mais en tout cas on peut finalement
trouver des solutions alors l'idée était
d'avoir je mens une approche
entrepreneuriale
alors je vous rassure j'ai pas pensé à
transformer des internes en boîte de
nuit mais je vous ai dit on peut créer
de la richesse
il ya beaucoup de toi il ya beaucoup de
terrain souvent autour des écoles donc
l'idée c'était d'utiliser les thouars
pour produire de l'énergie
photovoltaïque et utiliser les terrains
pour installer des potagers des vergers
une serre floral l'idée était donc de
créer de la richesse au sein de
l'internât pour améliorer le budget et
permettre au directeur de l'internât
donc d'améliorer les conditions de vie
et d'études des élèves afin qu'on puisse
enfin avoir des élèves des enfants qui
sont plus épanouis et des élèves qui
réussissent leurs études
l'amélioration du budget permet
aujourd'hui de financer des clubs qui
sont les clubs entrepreneuriat le club
culturel le club robotique
l'informatique legendre club qui traite
de l'éducation sexuelle pardon et de
l'égalité l'idée était finalement de
pallier au manque de l'état parce qu'il
faut reconnaître une chose
et d'ailleurs c'est quelque chose qui
m'a frappé quand j'ai découvert ça
figurez-vous qu'en tunisie le budget de
l'udc du ministère de l'éducation permet
d'entretenir toutes les écoles mais
quand on a un budget dont les trois
quarts sont consacrés à la masse
salariale on se retrouve avec très peu
pour entretenir les écoles et on se
retrouve dans un pays où bizarrement on
voit des écoles tomber en ruine à
l'ombre de mosquées qu'on construit à
partir ce moment là donc on a réussi à
fédérer beaucoup de monde et surtout de
l'entreprise privée je dois bien vous
cacher que moi il est temps on n'est pas
trop trop potes mais nous laisse agir
c'est déjà ça donc en tout cas avec des
entreprises privées et des étudiants qui
sont maintenant ambassadeur on a des
ambassadeurs ou à l'africaine sur tous
les continents qui sont mobilisés
justement pour faire connaître notre
mouvement nous avons enfin trouvé ce
système qui permet donc de créer de la
richesse au sein de l'internât pour
améliorer les conditions de vie et
d'études
aujourd'hui nous avons lancé une
approche scientifique également de ce
que nous faisons nous avons des
pédopsychiatres des statisticiens qui
sont en train de faire une étude pour
démontrer l'impact de ce que nous
faisons sur les enfants
parce qu'il faut parfois rappeler que
l'on mouiller surtout dans un pays où on
ignore certaines réalités
alors je vais maintenant vous montrer un
de nos projets qui vous donnera un
aperçu de ce que nous faisons
le sommeil dans la vie d'un jeune et
très important c'est important pour sa
santé c'est aussi important pour sa
scolarité et comme vous pouvez voir
actuellement dans les internats en doute
finalement que les enfants plus dormir
dans de bonnes conditions c'est pour ça
que l'association génération liberté
dans le cadre de son action week-end a
décidé d'imaginer une chambre ou des
camarades pourrait discuter s'amuser et
vivre entre eux mais également bouquiner
et étudier dans de bonnes conditions
voilà ça c'est une c'est un des projets
que nous avons vous aurez remarqué au
début les chambres ce sont des parce que
des cellules de prison ce sont des
limites à licques rouyer qui n'ont rien
d'humain et le problème était justement
celui là c'est à dire que quand il ya eu
la révolution est encore aujourd'hui en
tunisie les gens s'étonnent de ces
jeunes qu'ils soient pas engagés qui ne
s'impliquent pas mais on a beau leur
dire que finalement c'est tout à fait
normal parce que quand on ne permet pas
un enfant de grandir avec un cadre qui
soit un peu plus humain humaniste avec
certaines valeurs
on se retrouve forcément avec des jeunes
qui ne croient pas dans l'engagement
qu'il ne croit pas dans le travail
donc notre objectif aujourd'hui est de
préparer la prochaine génération à
écrire les premières pages du nist d'une
tunisie qui est libre avec un peuple
souverain
et en parlant d'histoire j'aime bien
terminer mes interventions avec
l'histoire du colibri
j'imagine que beaucoup la connaissent
j'ai quand même la raconter alors il
était une fois dans une forêt un énorme
incendie
et tandis que les animaux du gros
animaux sont en train de fuir et voit
des petits oiseaux qui font des allers
retours entre l' incendie et la rivière
et au bout d'un moment le lion s'arrête
un des gros animaux et 10 mai colibri
vous êtes fou comment vous imaginez avec
vos petits becs et ses petites gouttes
éteindre ses énormes flammes et les
colibris s'arrête et leur disent nous
faisons notre part nous faisons notre
part
[Applaudissements]